In the name of the Father, and of the Son, and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 24, on which we commemorate, our righteous
mother, Elizabeth, the Wonderworker.
On the 24th of the month, we celebrate the memory of our Holy Mother, Elizabeth, the Wonderworker.
Saint Elizabeth was given by God to her noble parents, devout Christians of Heraklia
and Thrace, following a miraculous intervention by the Holy Marjorie Glicaria.
From her earliest years, she learned the lives of the saints by heart, so that she was
able to follow the model of their evangelical conduct in every circumstance.
When she became an orphan, at the age of 12, she gave her inheritance away to the needy,
freed her slaves, and entered the Convent of St. George, popularly referred to, as, of
the Little Hill, in Constantinople, which was governed by her paternal aunt.
Embracing with zeal all the labors of the ascetic life, she rapidly became a chosen vessel of
divine grace.
The eyes of her heart were unceasingly fixed on the divine beauty, and to that end, for three
whole years she kept her gaze turned towards the ground, not allowing it to stray elsewhere.
She wore a single tunic and walked around with bare feet, even in winter, but the love
of God which burned in her heart served her for cloak and covering.
The tears she shed during the recitation of the Psalms were sweeter than any bath or perfume,
and for food she most often contented herself with the heavenly bread alone.
When the Abyss was on the point of leaving this life, she named Elizabeth her successor, and
it was the Holy Patriarch Yanadios in the years 458-471, who invested her.
God then redoubled the effects of his grace, and the saint worked many miracles, healing
incurable sicknesses, casting out demons, and predicting the future.
She warned the Emperor Leo in advance of the terrible fire that was to ravage the capital
in the year 465, which was also predicted by St. Daniel the Stylite, and it was thanks to
these two saints that the city was preserved from complete destruction.
As a sign of his gratitude, the Emperor gave her monastery the estate of St. Bobby-Las in
the Hebdumon district.
The place was, however, inhabited by a fearful dragon, which terrorized its inhabitants.
The saint went to the place, taking with her the precious cross, and she killed the dragon,
and trampled it under foot.
Her reputation as a wonder-worker spread throughout the imperial city, and, like a new unmercinary,
she healed the sicknesses of all who approached her.
One day, during the divine liturgy, she went into ecstasy and saw the Holy Spirit descend
like a great white luminous cloth to encompass the altar.
Towards the end of her life, St. Elizabeth returned to Heraclia, her homeland, to venerate
the holy places there.
St. Gliccharia appeared to her, reminding her of the protection she had given her from her
childhood, and inviting her to the heavenly country on the day after the feast of St. George.
According to her monastery, Elizabeth gave her last instructions to the sisters, and,
on the appointed day, having communicated in the holy mysteries, her face radiant like
the sun, she stretched out her hands towards heaven, and gave her soul into God's hands.
After having pronounced the words of righteous Simeon, Lord, now let us thou thy servant depart
in peace, for my eyes have seen thy salvation.
Elizabeth's body remained in corrupt, and was a source of healing for many centuries.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.